hello and good morning
uh my name is marcus madamsik and
i will talk today about interpolations
and mappings with applications to image
processing
all right let me just go right
to the start here and uh
talk about uh quickly the outline um the
outline will be as follows
uh to begin with i'll talk quickly about
interpolation and
approximation basics in case that's not
your cup of tea currently uh just to get
the
uh the foundation and then i'll be
talking about
uh well do a quick review about
interpolation in the wolfram language
uh just to point out what commands are
involved and then
i come to the new stuff uh it's so new
it's not going to be in
version 12.2 unfortunately it's going to
be about radial basis functions and thin
plate splines
that's an interpolation method
eventually to do
uh interpolations on irregular samplings
uh
be it now any kind of measurement or in
particular uh image processing
and at the end i'll be applying these uh
interpolation methods to
image warping and image registration
all right so um just to get started i
quickly define here
the set of data
points uh x data so just the positions
from one to ten
some uh values uh from one to uh not
from one to ten but on these uh
locations
and then uh also for later use the
derivatives of these data points just in
case i have those so if i were to
uh depict that quickly in a plot uh this
would be
uh a depiction of the data uh ranging
from one to ten
with derivatives and values okay so
um i'll be using these kind of data this
data set uh through the
entire talk so you'll be uh it will be
reoccurring
okay up front a quick distinction
between what's interpolation and what's
approximation
uh interpolation you basically have if
you have a discrete set of data points
and you construct
a continuous function that passes
through all the data points uh that can
be a
rather crude approximate uh
interpolation sorry
um when you just do a constants uh
so basically uh taking the floor
function or
a linear approximation or interpolation
i should say
here quadratic cubic all the way up to
high polynomial interpolations uh just
to give you an idea so that's
interpolation if the function that i
come up with
goes through the data if that's not the
case and i'll be talking about
approximation and that's going to be
just a side kick for this talk
approximations for example would be a
linear regression where you just
try to get some kind of model some kind
of function with lots of parameters
as close as as close as possible to the
data set so if you were to
fit a a parabola to this data that's
how it looks like and you note that that
function does not go through the data
points
all right so we'll be talking mainly
about interpolation
um okay so what's so difficult or hard
about interpolation
and for that purpose i'd like to address
right away the nyquist channel sampling
theorem which says
that you have to sample a signal or
any kind of data for that matter at a
rate that is about
twice or more the rate than the highest
frequency in the data
and you can see that very nicely here in
this little manipulate
uh i have here uh just a cyanoid wave
which i sample i can change here the
frequency
um and um here that's just interpolation
order so if i push the interlaced
order all the way up i get a very nice
interpolation except though
that if the sampling rate is too low
even a good
um interpolation won't do it because i
may just sample the signal in a very
unfortunate way as you can see here
uh it can you can have moire effects
the ringing effects that basically the
two frequencies
uh they modulate each other or
well if you basically push the sampling
rate to about half the highest
frequency of your signal you see that
the interpolation
gets rather nice and basically as soon
as the
interpolation is about twice or more the
highest frequency
uh the the sampling rate is about uh
twice or more uh the highest frequency
in your signal you do okay
so this was just a kind of a depiction
to quickly get that idea across
if i were to give you a mathematical
underpinning of this
i would resort to fourier space now i
won't explain furry transformation
just a few properties of fourier
transformation first if i would take for
example a cosine signal
and send it to fourier space
i get here two direct delta spikes
essentially
with some complex phases and as you can
see if i change the frequencies
of the signal i basically move these
spikes outward or inward
nothing much happens really it's just
moving in and out they don't move as
much
and if i basically change the phase of
the cosine if i move basically the wave
translate that you see that the signal
or the spectrum
in the fourier space does not move at
all
it's essentially invariant under
translations or the
spectral states here are eigenstates
under translation
now that's pretty handy to have and
that's why it's nice to work in fourier
space if you do interpolation because
essentially what you do in interpolation
is you know the values at a given
position and you want to move or
translate a little bit to the side and
see what the value
is there now if you're working in a
space where translation doesn't really
kick in it only
this basically gives you a complex phase
factor then that's already a good sign
so that's why we address fourier space
then there is another
aspect fourier space and that is if you
have a dirac
comb or if you're talking about temporal
data a spike train
so that you basically just have high
values
every other step well basically the step
size
uh age then that spike train
uh the sum of deltas the the rack comb
which by the way has this very
uh well interesting uh sign letter i'm
not sure if that has a
an analog on any kind of alphabet if you
know that by chance please let me know
via the chat
okay if that uh derock comb or
signal a spike train if that gets
translated into free space you'll
also get a dirac comb or spike train
except that the spacing is going to be
reciprocate that means if the spacing
here in position space gets bigger
the spacing of the
comb gets uh smaller in the fourier
space and vice versa
so if i sample very densely here with
the spike train
in position space i basically have a
very sparse
comb here in free space and vice versa
so let's keep that in mind
one other aspect about fourier is that
if you have a signal now we just take a
gaussian here
for simplicity and if i convert that
into fourier space usually
if it's well focused the signal
has a nice position in position space
if it has sharp edges you usually have a
very broad
spectrum in fourier space and if
everything is smeared out in position
space you usually have a very strong
spike
in fourier space so just that to keep in
mind
now let's assume we want to
sample now the signal which just happens
to be the gaussian distribution but it
could be anything
um if you want to sample that well
essentially what we do is we just
multiply that with a spike train with
the
dirac comb and then we end up with just
the values
of this uh gaussian
distribution on the integer or whatever
positions the comb has
so we can do that and if we do that we
basically get here kind of a discrete
regular sampling
of my signal and since
uh a sample multiplication and position
space translates to a convolution in uh
in fourier space you can just convolve
now
the signal that you had in our case the
gaussian with the comb and you
essentially get replicas
of your signal in frequency space now
that's all
good and nice as long as these things
don't overlap because
if i now reduce the
oh sorry i reduce the sampling in
position space you see that the sampling
points they move
outward on the other hand the
signal here the replicas they start to
overlap
and that's by the way then a good sign
for what's called
aliasing uh effects that you don't want
because at the end of the day
you want to reconstruct just the center
signal here as soon as these things
overlap
you essentially have a signal here that
you cannot take apart anymore that's the
sum of two
components that you can't take apart
anymore so what you like to have is
you'd like to
make sure that uh your sampling
is in such a way that the signal here in
the spectrum
and its replicas are well separated
because if that's so
then let me move on
then you can do the following you can
multiply
the fourier space just with a box or
unit box a function that goes basically
from
one boundary of your wrapper class to
the next and then it just basically
singles out
just the center part which was the
original signal
and deletes all the replicas now if you
delete all the replicas and then do the
inverse transformation you should end up
with a continuous signal and
interestingly though
here you essentially do a multiplication
that again is now a convolution here
so that essentially you have to convolve
the original sequent position space
with the free transform of the inverse
fourier transform of the unit box
and that happens to be the sink function
so
ideally this simplifies just to the
signal itself in this uh area
and that's then transferred uh
transformed back it's just the
convolution
of this discrete signal with the
sync function okay and that's
essentially
the basics of uh resampling theory
and so all we have to do is basically
find a kernel
with which we convolve the discrete data
and
ideally that should be the sink function
the sine of x divided by x or rather
sine of pi x divided by pi x now
unfortunately sine of x divided by x has
a very large
extent uh it goes from minus infinity to
infinity so
numerically that's not something uh easy
to convolve with
so at the end of the day we have to do a
poor man solution we can do
a linear spike we can
do some nice polynomial in this case the
catmull rom
kernel which is defined here we can have
the sync function
with some signal signal
signaling window in this case a hamming
window and
cut it off somewhere or we can do
uh combined
resamplings like the spline or the
omom's kernel
which essentially is a kernel that is
finite
and then combined with the
with the recursive filter can be
made up into a pretty good approximation
of the sink function itself
all right um so um
here we are have uh
in in store essentially all the uh
samplings that you can choose from uh
just to give you an overview
these are all the available ones and
then you can retrieve data about these
samplings like the properties
uh the kernel the free kernel and so
forth so
uh for the uh all moms um i
almost by the way stands for um splines
of maximal order and minimal support so
they're pretty
efficient uh to calculate and have
pretty good quality
we have this spline function that we
convolve with and once we
well that is not the sync function but
once we uh
add the recursion filter on top of it uh
we essentially
de-blur it and then we get this uh
effective kernel and at the end of the
day we then have
this kind of function with which we
convolve the data and that's pretty good
so we can
now also get properties of that kernel
it is
continuous but it is not continuous its
derivatives you see little kinks here by
the way
uh which is bad if you want to take the
derivatives of the resulting data
but this happens to be at least when it
comes to
reduction of noise to be the best
possible implementation
you can calculate the basic support
which gives you about an idea about the
efficiency
because the smaller the support of the
kernel the less calculations you have to
do
all right so so much for the theory
behind it and
uh now also a little uh bit
the entire thing in fourier space how
does a kernel inferior space look like
a deal would be a box a kind of
structure but you can see that uh this
kernel already has a pretty box-like
uh spectrum uh and uh
that's good in order to uh to basically
uh attenuate out all the replicas of the
signal that you get due to the uh
sub sampling all right this would be
just another plot and into an
attenuation plot sorry that's a tough
word for me um
and that gives you an idea how well you
subdue the signal outside the
center okay let me move
on okay last but not least
you can then also get the error kernel
which gives you an idea
where the error of the approximation
kicks in
here wherever we find frequencies uh
under the blue
shaded area these frequencies would
lead to an error in the approximation so
any signal that is
somewhat here in the middle is fine and
then what's also a good
uh measure is to see by what order you
go
up here on the side if it's a polynomial
of second third fourth fifth order
because that order determines how much
or how fast you
approximate the true function when you
decrease the step size
of your sampling and in this case you
see uh with
omom's of third order i have an
approximation of
fourth order at hand
okay uh right so let's apply this now
that was the theory
the dry stuff uh so let's apply this
quickly to image transformation
where does it kick in here it kicks in
because uh when you create a new image
then essentially what you do is you take
the inverse transformation
which takes the position back to the
original image and here you have to pick
up the color of the image which you
basically get by interpolating
between the pixel values that you have
here so that's where the interpolation
kicks in
so i can do this here with image
perspective transformation
uh this uh then uh
yeah you can do whatever you want this
is no rocket science you can
rotate your image you can translate you
can do whatever transformation you want
and then the resampling essentially
gets you the image back now what's
interesting is that if we take for
example
very good quality a kernel that i just
outlined not just all
moms of third order but there may be all
months of fifth order
the quintic order you essentially get as
i pointed out already uh very much sync
like kernel so you should pick up the
signal very well
and we can just compare what happens uh
to image processing
so what i've done here uh quickly just
show you the code
is i rotated the image in steps of 10
degrees
and i do it once basically around and at
the end of the day
36 uh times 10 degrees is 360 degrees so
i
rotate the image back to its original
position but i do that in 36 steps and
in one case
i just take linear uh resampling in one
case i could take catmull rom
which is a medium quality one and then i
take my omom's
five and uh just to show you the quality
difference this is a linear
transformation and you see that errors
accumulate while you rotate
this is when you do one step better cut
more rom
and this for example is a quintic omom
and you can see essentially all the data
the fine hairy
stuff uh at this animal can be
reproduced
even if you do a transformation 36 times
in a row so there you see the
quality gain that you achieve by
taking some interest into interpolation
now where does interpolation kick in
for um in the mathematical language well
we have
for example interpolation order when you
do plots like a listline plot
you can interpolate uh usually by
default linearly
but you can also uh determine higher
order of interpolation let's say quintic
uh or uh cubic interpolation
zero order would be just staircase
linear interpolation
uh quadratic cubic and so on so there
you don't have to do anything you just
choose um the appropriate option
then we have another way to interpolate
just discrete data if it's regularly
sampled and that's arrays
resampling array resampling essentially
takes a list or two-dimensional
four-dimensional whatever
dimensional array and re-samples that
in a different step size and there are
two different schemes that i just like
to point out because
you could for example have a point
sampling if your data was just always
sampled at a given point then this would
be the scheme to apply
however if your data was basically
sampled in little bins
then taking a different step size as on
has a different positioning
scheme where you want to read off the
interpolating function
so array resample comes with a point or
bin resampling scheme which you specify
here in the third argument
in this particular case i take my data
resample it by a factor of
four uh higher sampling
and i do just a cubic sampling so that
looks like this the red
dots were the original data points the
blue ones are the ones that i know
added what's also uh of
some importance to some people is that
array sample comes with all kinds of
paddings
so i cannot just do a padding that for
example does
a null padding at the side or a fixed
padding
for reflective padding you can do any
kind of pairing also
a periodic padding and then you get here
the slightly different behavior
on the ends of your domain interpolation
domain because here essentially the
signal has to
go up again to meet the uh the last
point here
okey dokey so that's uh if you want to
quickly
sample uh just
an array otherwise if you sample any
data you can also
just create the interpolating function
itself and that's done by interpolation
or list interpolation
and what you get back is not now an
array but you get a container
interpolating function container back
and with that you can well do any kind
of plot as well
this thing behaves pretty much like a
function here for example
the hermite interpolation of my data set
now if you wonder ever wondered why this
has these funny shapes that's because
well just look it up
uh the kernel of hermit impellation
interpolation when it's
even of an even order has usually a very
weird shape and that's very intuitive
that may be
misleading a little bit um the nice
thing about hermit interpolation though
is that you can also apply that to data
where you have derivatives so that you
not only fit
the absolute value of the data but also
sorry
also the uh the derivatives that you may
have at hand
and then we get an interpolation that
looks like this here so also up to
higher orders if you like all right
okay last but not least the
interpolating function itself has some
nice properties once you have
interplayed something it can for example
do a taylor expansion
you can take derivatives or you can
integrate
so this thing really behaves very much
like an ordinary function in mathematica
and because that's so any function a
numerical function that has to return
a function like structure like nbsal for
example
does take advantage of it it does not
return a
discrete set of points to approximate
the function
that you try to solve for but it returns
as you can see an
interpolating function um
that not only holds true for uh 1d in
this case for by the way you see it is a
hermite polynomial third order
it's not periodic but you can also do
that for 2d for example here
a differential partial differential
equation on a disk
and when you look more closely here you
see that this is a method that's called
unstructured
and what happens here is essentially
that this thing this is the prox uh the
the function being plotted basically
utilizes the finite element methods that
are built into
nvsov and it defines the approximation
on this
uh element on this finite element grid
and every node now has a point and in
between
you have in this particular case a
quadratic second order
interpolation now in case you didn't
know
and i have to admit i didn't know
because it sneaked in with version 7 i
believe
is that you can also use that or utilize
that
in interpolation for cases where you
don't have
a regular sampling of your data
now um i assume here are basically
quickly generated on the fly the height
values around mount everest
and of course you may not be uh not
every point on that mod
may be accessible so you most likely
have an irregular
set of data points uh you can
get the neighborhood relations by the
learning mesh and that's exactly what
happens by the way here in interpolation
uh which unfortunately can only do for
that mesh up to first order
uh and that generates an interpolating
function that is defined
on that mesh and that can reproduce here
the data in a continuous form so this
would be how the mod everest looks like
under this measurement now you see that
this is not great
so there are better ways to do it uh and
for that matter
let me move on on uh to the next topic
of
my talk and that is radial basis
functions
or in the particular case it's most
popular
thin plate splines now in this kind of a
pro
interpolation scheme you work as follows
you have
this kind of function that you try to
fit to the data points
you have an affine essentially
transformational function with a matrix
linear part and a constant offset uh
which basically
if you look at for example just a
one-dimensional case when you have
points p1 that you'd like to map to q1
q2 and so forth
uh that you basically approximate the
first
mapping by just a linear mapping and
then you take
care of all the non-linear deviations
and do that by
a weighted sum of radial basis functions
essentially functions that just
basically measure
or depend on the difference between the
anchor point that you're looking at and
the point that you try to project to
and they are just radial dependent uh
files and
for special uh cases of these like a
thin plate spline radial basis functions
you get interpolations with a pretty
good property
i won't go into the detail how you
calculate the w's
a and b is easy the nice thing about
these things is they don't not only work
for one-dimensional to one-dimensional
mappings but they work for all kinds of
mappings so they work for mappings from
2d to 2d
from 1t to 2d from 2d to 1d
to any dimension you like and for image
processing it's an interesting case that
you have 2d to duty because
that way you can construct warping
transformations from one set of discrete
points to another set of discrete points
and that's exactly what we're going to
try now and
the radio function uh that i take into
account is the thin plate
thin plate spline function uh which
has different versions for depending on
what kind of dimensionality you're
working in in 1d it's r
cubed in 2d it's r squared log of
r in 3d it's just r and
the nice property of this set of
template spine radial basis functions is
that
they minimize this functional and this
functional basically says okay i
minimize
the differences between
my data points and my interpolation
function
and times the parameter which basically
then
determines the regularization i minimize
the curvature so essentially that's why
they're also called splines
they minimize the curvature of the fit
okay having said that let's just
generate
here the radial basis transform of
the data this function by the way is not
yet in the system it is attached to this
notebook which you can obtain
after this talk by a passable
so this generates a regular basis
transform which eventually will be
an interpolating transform but that is
not decided yet when it comes to the
design decisions
and uh so this radial basis transform
depending on
what lambda is will try to get a very
smooth
uh function through the data set with
more or less curvature
now the two day case the 1d case is not
the interesting one let's
address the one t to 2d case again the
height measurements around
mount everest so uh again here's a data
set
of height measurements and now i send
that uh through
not interp interpolation but radial
basis transform
and this again gives me now a transform
that gives me all the heights
again i plot these heights and you can
see that now i not only have a linear
but a quadratic interpolation of all
these height values and they give a
pretty good
reproduction of the altitudes
of mount everest okay another
application
another application here is the warping
of in this case mona lisa i just
basically have here predetermined a few
points on the face of mona lisa they are
depicted here by very small red
dots which i'm not sure you can see and
those dots i can now move
that means thereby define
a radial basis transformation that maps
the old dots into the new dots and for
example i can pick the eye
and pull the eye to one side or
i can give her a really good smile
and you can see you can also do that
with any kind of
uh photograph if you want to so this is
a great
thing to have fun uh with the data at
hand
one more serene application is for
example
the warping or the morphology of
biological structures for example this
is a skull of a german shepherd dog
this is the skull of a british bulldog
and you can see that they look quite
different but if you find the morphing
map that takes this car to this car you
see that they are not
that different at after all all i have
to do is i have to specify a few key
points on one skull and
the corresponding key points on the
other one this gives me now a radio
basis transform
which basically gives me the
transformation of the
german shepherd into a british bulldog
and then we can compare those two skulls
and you see that
essentially they look very much the same
the lighting unfortunately is different
on these two photographs but
the morphology of the entire skull is
pretty much the same
and last but not least uh to get done in
time
here another application that would be
image registration
given i two images that have an overlap
i can try to find
corresponding key points in the um
in the image here on the left and right
and this is what i get
so just to depict them i have here
or where these uh violet little points
are around this area and here
i have corresponding points and those i
can now just utilize
to generate without throwing any point
away as i do with perspective
transformations
i can just create a radial basis
transform that takes all these points
into this
and fills a transformation in between to
make it a continuous transformation
and then i can take the original image
sorry the second image
warp it onto the original image stitch
them together
and just last but not least i can also
utilize some
additional image processing in
mathematica
that is in painting to fill the gaps on
the side to obtain
a bigger image all right so this was a
kind of a tour de force through
uh all the interpolation techniques that
we have in the world from language
next up if you're interested in image
processing
object detection and recognition with
giulio right
next and later today we have an office
hour
sound and vision at 10 am
central time or whatever time zone you
are in
so that's about two hours from now
thanks for attending thanks for
listening
and bye-bye